the Joe Rogan experience it's something
else interesting and when you talk about
China though is and and you think about
okay what should we be watching we
touched on Russia a little bit is the
alliance between possible alliance
between Russia and China and it's an
interesting dynamic you know
traditionally Russia trying to have them
been together they've always been some
areas of concern
you know distrust but there are signs
there are things happening that appear
as if China and Russia have made a
strategic decision to align themselves
closer and that would be because they've
made that determination that somehow
it's in their best interests of you know
not necessarily that it's going to be
that way for any long period of time but
right now in the current environment you
see Russia acting as if what they want
is a stronger alliance military alliance
and political alliance economic alliance
with China and it's it's it's an
interesting dynamic that we need to be
watching we need to be aware of and and
part of that is you know people again
this this idea that you know there was
this Russia Trump collusion and thinking
okay well that's good except our
relations with Russia haven't been this
bad in a long time so maybe it's all a
very clever mind game that they're
playing because they're closely aligned
but I don't think so so we've actually
laid on more significant sanctions on
Russia we've attacked them from an
energy perspective in terms of our
ability to create our independence you
know particularly from from natural gas
that is damaged Russia's abilities so I
think there's reasons why they're
gravitating towards China right now but
this idea that somehow Trump is super
friendly and as a useful idiot of Putin
it doesn't doesn't play out when you
look at the reality of the relationship
between the two countries that whole
Russia and collusion thing is a very
confusing narrative because on one hand
you have the Democrats who are saying
without doubt there's Russian collusion
and then the other side you have the
Republicans and say the Mueller report
essentially exonerated Trump from being
a part of any sort of rush inclusion I
don't think either one is totally
accurate I think there's a lot of like
weird gray yeah both narratives I think
that the Democrat narrative is easier to
understand it just makes sense from
their perspective why one's how he
wanted
why wouldn't we push that to this day
they're just still amazed that they lost
and so there must be some grander reason
why because we just how clearly we
couldn't lose to this guy right so and
it was also a talking more much less you
know let's hit everybody with the racist
hammer it's a talking point and it's
worked for them over yeah at least the
first couple of years on the on the on
the Republican side look the Russians
knew what they were doing right they
were [ __ ] with the election on several
different levels it wasn't just trolling
through the internet it wasn't you know
just placing stories that they could it
wasn't just trying to film it you know a
divisive miss and discontent it was also
doing these little dangle things you
know or they're you know they're looking
to see what are they gonna bite what are
they gonna do you know I mean you think
about that Christopher steel dossier
that was a piece of [ __ ] I mean if we
saw that in in the commercial side of
things you know I've got a business and
global intelligence and and and research
and security that thing was just there
was nothing it was shot full of holes
right and so you think well what
somebody should have asked tell me about
your sources you know why are your
sources talking what was you know you've
got a anytime you've got a piece of
intelligence right you got to a few
basic things you know way to come from
the people that steeled us it was all
about yeah it was basically just look
they were going after opposition
research political opposition research
and so Christopher Steele who was a you
know a paid hired consultant used to be
with British intelligence not you know
not a James Bond type but you know a
decent enough by all accounts a decent
enough guy but he entered the world of
private sector information gathering
right and I've got a company that's
whether we do all around the world and
and you you can't relax your standards
just because you're now in the
commercial sector right when you get a
piece of information you need to test
that piece of information and one of the
first things you need
do as understand what's the sourcing for
it and why did why did they have access
you know how credible are they what's
their track record and why by the way
are they providing this information and
how did it eventually you know make its
way to this report and those are the
sort of simple things that whether
you're a corporation that's gathering
intelligence about a market that you may
enter with a you know an investment or
whether you're still in the business and
you're an Intel officer and you're you
know talking to a source that works in
some foreign ministry somewhere you got
to be able to you know stress test the
intelligence and then it [ __ ] wasn't
done people people liked what they saw
they saw negative information about the
the candidate and just run with that
[ __ ] right and the more times you it's
like it's like the old WMD reporting
that came out of the early days in Iraq
the more you repeat it even if it's one
source and that source is a piece of
[ __ ] what you repeated people are gonna
buy it
alright so right conclusion Russian
collusion you just keep repeating that
and it's gonna happen at some point
it'll happen but anyway so but it seems
like Russia definitely likes to disrupt
our democracy absolutely and then once
the enha fit of that well part of it is
in in the old days it was sort of a
struggle for supremacy in the world
right i mean that was that's kind of its
core that's what it was right and their
ability to chip away in faith into
democratic institutions was at the core
of a lot of the crap that they pulled
and it still is I mean so that's all
they when you're talking about a
propaganda effort like the the screwing
with the last election what's their goal
when the goal isn't necessarily it
that's where they you know do they care
whether one Canada or another wins well
maybe maybe they do right but you'd be
hard-pressed to argue that you know they
were working against Hillary Clinton who
had said you know we want to have a
reset and you know and have a new
relationship with Russia and work with
them I mean maybe they looked at Trump
and thought yeah that's a guy we want to
work with but over that the more
important issue was in just chipping
away at Americans belief in democratic
institutions get us all so that we
question the credibility of a democracy
and that
then the fundamental belief for
propaganda efforts within the old KGB
and now the FSU and and and so it's it's
you know it's as simple as that in a way
and it worked
look at this you know we spent years now
just bitching at each other and yelling
and screaming and complaining and we
bought into it because we all like we
talked about before we you know we're
easily duped and and I don't know how
you get around that I don't know how we
walk that back maybe we don't but I
think it's an informed public that that
helps to battle this but we haven't we
lost sight of what was important here
and that is and so I think the public
needs it's their responsibility you like
this you know you like where you live
then you gotta make an effort to try to
keep it right and and part of that is
being an informed public and
understanding what the hostile elements
may be out there you know without being
paranoid but just understand why they're
doing things in the way that the world
operates
[Applause]